결국 모든 qubit에 해당되는 거예요. 노이즈 측면에서는 꽤 극단적이지만, 한 가지 할 수 있는 건 이 채널과 항등 채널의 볼록 결합을 고려하는 거예요.
완전 편극 제거에 아마도 작은 확률 엡실론으로요.
이건 덜 극단적인 형태의 노이즈인데, 주어진 qubit 상태가 대부분 그대로 있지만
완전히 혼합될 작은 가능성이 있어요. 기하학적으로는 블로흐 구가 중심 쪽으로 약간 수축하는 것으로 생각할 수 있어요.
그리고 비슷한 걸 완전 위상 제거 채널로도 할 수 있는데, 예를 들어 디코히어런스 과정을 모델링하기 위해서요.
어떤 과정을 통해 약간 더 고전적이 되는 것처럼요. 이것들이 qubit 채널의 세 가지 기본 예시이고,
강의의 나머지 부분에서 주로 예시의 원천으로 다시 다룰 거예요. 다음으로 채널의 수학적
표현에 대해 논의할 건데, 기본적인 질문부터 시작해요. 벡터에서 벡터로의 선형 사상은 항상
익숙한 방식으로 행렬로 표현될 수 있어요. 선형 사상의 작용이 행렬
벡터 곱셈으로 표현되는 방식으로요. 하지만 채널은 행렬에서 행렬로의 선형 사상이지, 벡터에서 벡터로가 아니에요.
그래서 일반적으로 채널을 수학적으로 어떻게 표현할 수 있을까요? 특별한 채널에 대해서는 때로
간단한 공식이 있는데, 앞서 논의한 qubit 채널 예시들이 그런 경우였어요. 하지만 그건
일반적으로 실용적이지 않아요. 그런 좋은 공식이 항상 있는 건 아니거든요. 비교 대상으로, 양자 정보의 단순화된
공식화에서는 양자 상태 벡터에 대한 연산을 나타내기 위해 unitary 행렬을 사용해요.
모든 unitary 행렬이 유효한 연산을 나타내고, 모든 유효한 연산이 unitary 행렬로 표현될 수 있어요. 본질적으로
이 질문이 묻는 건 채널에 대해서는 어떻게 하냐는 거예요. 이 질문의 답은 채널을 수학적으로 표현하는 방법이
실제로 여러 가지 있다는 거예요. 특히 채널을 표현하는 세 가지 다른 방법을 논의할 건데,
그 개발에 중요한 역할을 한 세 사람의 이름을 딴 것들이에요. Stinespring, Kraus, 그리고 Choi예요.
먼저 이 다양한 표현들이 어떻게 작동하는지 살펴보고, 강의의 마지막 부분에서 세 표현이 어떻게 관련되는지,
특히 어떻게 변환할 수 있는지 살펴볼 거예요. 또한 이 표현들이 채널에 대한 요건들을 정확히 포착한다는 것도 알게 될 거예요.
즉, 선형 사상이어야 하고, 복합 시스템의 일부에만 적용될 때도
항상 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환해야 한다는 거예요. 첫 번째로 Stinespring 표현을 다룰 거예요. William Forrest Stinespring은
양자 정보 연구를 하지 않은 수학자였고, 제가 설명할 Stinespring 표현은
어떤 의미에서 1950년대 연산자 이론에 관한 그의 연구의 파생물에 불과해요. 하지만 이 연구는 분명히
양자 채널의 기반이 되는 수학 발전의 중요한 부분이었어요. 채널을 표현하는 이 방법의 아이디어는 모든
채널이 제가 이제 설명할 특정 방법으로 구현될 수 있다는 거예요. 먼저 구현하려는 채널의
입력과 초기화된 작업 공간 시스템으로 구성된 복합 시스템을 형성해요. 그런 다음
복합 시스템에 unitary 연산을 수행하고, 마지막으로 결과 복합 시스템에서
채널의 출력에 해당하는 부분은 그대로 두거나 출력하고 나머지는 버리거나 trace out해요. 이걸
다이어그램 형태로 표현하면 이해하기 쉬운데, 입력과 출력 시스템이 같은 특수한 경우부터 시작하는 게 가장 간단해요.
이 다이어그램은 quantum circuit 다이어그램과 같은데, 선들이 임의의 시스템을 나타내고 반드시 단일 qubit일 필요는 없어요.
그래서 입력 시스템 X가 어떤 상태 ρ에 있는 것부터 시작해요. 초기화된 작업 공간 시스템 W를 도입하고,
이 다이어그램에서는 0이 W의 고전적 상태이고 시스템의 초기화된 상태로 |0⟩을 취하고 있지만,
W의 임의의 순수 상태를 대신 고정해서 초기화된 상태로 볼 수도 있어요. 그런 다음 쌍 WX에 unitary 연산을 수행하고
작업 공간 시스템을 trace out하고 X를 출력해요. 다이어그램에서 W가 버려진다는 걸 나타내기 위해
전기 공학의 접지 기호를 쓰고 있어요. 이게 반드시 관례적인 건 아니고, Qiskit에서는 찾을 수 없을 거예요.
Qiskit에서는 관심 없는 qubit들을 그냥 무시해요. 중요한 건 이 논의를 위해 시스템이 버려진다는 걸
명확히 하는 기호가 필요하다는 거예요. 일반적으로 입력과 출력 시스템이 같을 필요는 없어서,
예를 들어 출력 시스템 Y와 함께
trace out되는 쓰레기 시스템 G가 있을 수 있어요. U가 unitary이려면 정방 행렬이어야 하므로,
쌍 GY가 쌍 WX와 같은 수의 고전적 상태를 갖는다는 가정이 있어요. 예를 들어 이 시스템들이
qubit들로 구성되고, 입력 시스템 X가 5개의 qubit, W가 10개의 qubit로 구성된다면, U는 15 qubit에 대한 unitary
연산이에요. 그러면 Y가 4개의 qubit로만 구성될 수 있고, G는 11개의 qubit로 구성돼요.
아니면 이게 qubit이 전혀 아닐 수도 있어요. 중요한 건 WX와 GY가 함께 같은 수의 고전적 상태를 가져야
U가 unitary일 수 있다는 거예요. 이런 식의 채널 설명을 채널의 Stinespring 표현이라고 해요. 이제
이런 식으로 설명될 수 있는 임의의 사상 Φ가 실제로 유효한 채널임을 주장하기 꽤 쉬워요.
특히 밀도 행렬에서 시작해서 추가적인 작업 공간 시스템을 덧붙이면, 분명히
밀도 행렬이 남아요. unitary 연산을 적용하면 유효한 채널을 준다는 건 이미 알았고,
복합 시스템의 밀도 행렬에서 시스템 중 하나를 trace out하면, 다시 밀도 행렬이 남아요. 이 단계들을
합성하면 항상 밀도 행렬을 밀도 행렬로 변환함이 보장되고, 또한 선형이에요.
이 시점에서 전혀 명확하지 않은 건, 모든 채널이 실제로 작업 공간 시스템과 쓰레기 시스템,
그리고 물론 unitary 연산 U에 대한 어떤 선택으로 이런 방식으로 구현될 수 있다는 거예요. 하지만 그건 사실이고,
강의 끝에서 왜 그런지 알게 될 거예요. 여기 완전 위상 제거 qubit 채널에 대한 Stinespring 표현 예시가 있어요.
명확히 말하면, 이제 선들은 qubit이고, 이건 일반적인 controlled-NOT gate예요.
매우 간단해요. 입력 qubit은 위에 있고, 영 상태로 초기화된 작업 공간 qubit을 도입해요.
그런 다음 입력 qubit이 제어이고 작업 공간 qubit이 타겟인 controlled-NOT 연산을 수행하고,
작업 공간 qubit을 trace out해요. 직관적으로, 이게 완전 위상 제거 채널을 구현해야 한다는 게 말이 돼요.
controlled-NOT gate가 위의 qubit에 표준 기저 측정처럼 작동해서 고전적 상태를 아래 qubit에 복사하고,
그런 다음 결과가 버려지기 때문이에요.
하지만 계산을 직접 해볼 수도 있고, 물론 그렇게 하는 게 좋아요. 왜냐하면 정말로